NEW YORK CITY AND THIS IS
"THE FIVE"
"THE FIVE."
THE DEMOCRATS ARE DESPERATELY
TRYING TO REVIVE THE RUSSIAN
INCLUSION TALKING POINTS AHEAD
OF THIS WEEK'S HEARING WITH
SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER,
NOW EVEN THOUGH MUELLER DID NOT
FIND COLLUSION IN THE DOJ RULED
THERE WAS NO OBSTRUCTION,
DEMOCRATS REFUSE TO ACCEPT
REALITY AND MOVE ON.
FOR EXAMPLE HOW SHOULD
JERRY NADLER SAID THE REPORT
COULD PROVIDE EVIDENCE FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
>> THE REPORT PRESENTS
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE THE
PRESIDENT WITH MISDEMEANORS AND
WE HAVE TO PRESENT OR LET
MUELLER PRESENT THOSE FACTS TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND SEE
WHERE WE GO FROM THERE.
THE ADMINISTRATION MUST BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND NO PRESIDENT CAN
BE ABOVE THE LAW.
>> Jesse: ADAM SCHIFF IS GOING
FURTHER CLAIMING HE CAN GO TO
JAIL.
>> HE IS ESSENTIALLY UNINDICTED
CODE CONSPIRACY OR AN INDIVIDUAL
ONE AS THE PERSON WHO DIRECTED
MICHAEL: WITH THIS FRAUDULENT
CAMPAIGN SCHEME AND MIKE,
IF THE EVIDENCE SUPPORTS THAT HE
IF THE EVIDENCE SUPPORTS THAT HS
IF THE EVIDENCE SUPPORTS THAT HO
IF THE EVIDENCE SUPPORTS THAT HL
IF THE EVIDENCE SUPPORTS THAT HD
IF THE EVIDENCE SUPPORTS THAT HN
IF THE EVIDENCE SUPPORTS THAT HI
IF THE EVIDENCE SUPPORTS THAT HT
IF THE EVIDENCE SUPPORTS THAT HD
IF THE EVIDENCE SUPPORTS THAT H.
SPEED FOR HOW GREEN NOT GIVING
UP ON IMPEACHMENT FANTASY.
>> AT THIS PRESIDENT WILL BE
IMPEACHED, I AM CONVINCED OF IT.
I BELIEVE MY COLLEAGUES ARE
MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION AND I
TRUST THAT WILL HAPPEN SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER.
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT TRUMP
DISMISSING THE HEARING TO
RESURRECT THE WITCH HUNT.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO BE WATCHING
PROBABLY MAYBE I WILL SEE A
LITTLE BIT BUT I WILL NOT BE
WATCHING MUELLER BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T TAKE ALL THOSE BITES OUT
OF THE APPLE.
WE HAD NO COLLUSION, NO
OBSTRUCTION, NO NOTHING.
WE HAD A TOTAL NO COLLUSION
FINDING.
THE DEMOCRATS WERE DEVASTATED BY
IT.
ALL THEY CARE ABOUT IS A PONY
INVESTIGATION.
>> Jesse: HE WILL DEFTLY NOT
BE WATCHING THE MUELLER HEARING.
>> THE THING I'VE ENJOYED MOST
ABOUT THIS PRESIDENT SAYED THE
3,000 ASPECT WHERE HE DOES LIVE
TWEET ALONG WITH ALMOST
EVERYTHING.
AND I REALLY HOPE HE DOES.
HE SHOULDN'T HOLD BACK.
BUT THIS IS THE TIME AND PLACE
FOR DIGESTING THINGS IN REAL
TIME.
BUT YOU KNOW, YOU WERE SAYING
THE DEMOCRATS ARE DUSTING OFF
THE RUSSIAN INCLUSION TALKING
POINTS.
THEY BETTER SKIP AHEAD TO 2020
BECAUSE THE CHINESE ARE LOOKING
AT THE RUSSIANS GOING, AMATEURS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WITH INFILTRATED THE SOFTWARE
AND DONE SO MUCH MORE.
>> Jesse: THAT IS THE COMPANY
YOU ARE REFERRING TO, THE
SOFTWARE AND NET WORKING BUT DO
YOU THINK THE DEMOCRATS OR
LIVING IN THE PAST?
>> Juan: I REALLY DON'T
UNDERSTAND IT.
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT IS SAYING
THE DEMOCRATS AND MUELLER CAN'T
HAVE A SECOND BITE AT THE APPLE.
THIS WILL BE BAD FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
HE IS APPARENTLY ALARMED THAT
HE'S GOT SOMETHING TO HIDE.
I THOUGHT NO CONSTRUCTION,
SOMETHING.
>> Jesse: A 400 PAGE REPORT.
>> Juan: HE SHOULD ASK MUELLER
TO STAND UP AND SAY EXACTLY
WHAT'S IN THE REPORT.
INSTEAD, HE'S RUNNING MY YOU
KNOW LIKE SOMETHING'S WRONG.
NOBODY PAY ATTENTION.
NOBODY HOME, NOBODY HERE.
>> Jesse: HE LOOKED LIKE HE
WAS SITTING TO ME, TYRANTS, THIS
IS LIKE MUELLER HEARING WAIT.
>> THIS WHOLE PROCESS I WOULD GO
WITH THE MUELLER REPORT.
TYPICALLY AN INVESTIGATION
HAPPENS I LIKE TO GET TO THE END
BEFORE WE PASS JUDGMENT, WEIRD
THAT WAY.
I DON'T THINK MUELLER WAS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD GUIDE.
I DON'T SEE HIM SAYING ANYTHING
DIFFERENT EXCEPT TURN TO PAGE 35
FOR EVERY QUESTION THEY ASK.
QUESTION NUMBER 27, I DON'T
THINK THIS WILL BE AN EXCITING
DAY FOR EITHER SIDE.
AT THE END OF THIS, THE
DEMOCRATS THINKS HE COMMITTED A
HIGH CRIME AND REPUBLICANS DON'T
BELIEVE HE DID.
THAT WILL BE THE END OF THE DAY.
>> Jesse: HE'S NOT AN EXCITING
PERSON BUT THE MOST EXCITING
PART WILL BE THE REPUBLICANS ON
THE COMMITTEE ASKING TOUGH
QUESTIONS THAT MUELLER HAS NOT
ANSWERED.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WHEN DID YOU DETERMINE THERE WAS
NO CONSPIRACY?
AT WHAT POINT THE LAST WARRANT
RENEWAL IN JUNE 2017, YOU DIDN'T
RENEW IT IN THE FALL.
DID YOU FIND OUT THEN AND WHY
DIDN'T YOU LET THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE KNOW THERE WAS NO
CONSPIRACY BEFORE THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS?
WHY DIDN'T YOU INVESTIGATE THE
PREDICATE OF ORIGINAL
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE?
WHAT LAUNCHED THIS?
CAN YOU TELL US THAT?
IT IS GOING TO BE A FIELD OH
FOUR -- FIELD DAY FOR
REPUBLICANS.
JERRY NADLER IS TRYING TO RUFFLE
UP IMPEACHMENT BECAUSE THE
NUMBERS HAVE BEEN FALLING.
21% ACCORDING TO LATEST
"WALL STREET JOURNAL"'S NEWS
POLL.
THE SHARE OF AMERICANS IN FAVOR
OF IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS.
21% DOWN SIX POINTS AND EVEN
DOWN NINE POINTS TO 39% FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
SO TRYING TO HAVE A DOG AND PONY
SHOW.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS NO DOGS OR
PONIES WILL BE THERE.
DOGS AND PONIES ARE AWESOME AND
IT'S AN OLD ROOSTER BOB MUELLER
AND A BUNCH OF WEIBEL WOBBLER'S.
>> Juan: BILL BARR, BILL BARR
ABSOLUTELY SAID NO OBSTRUCTION,
NO COLLUSION.
AND BILL BARR SAID GO AHEAD
MR. MUELLER TESTIFIED.
>> THEN I THINK THAT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING BECAUSE IF YOU
HAVE SOME SORT OF DIPLOMAT
BETWEEN WHAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID WHEN HE
SUMMARIZED THE REPORT AND THE
AUTHOR OF THE REPORT,
ROBERT MUELLER, THEN REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS SHOULD TRY TO
RECONCILE.
BUT I THINK THAT IT'S VERY FAIR.
AND I THINK WE SHOULD GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THAT BECAUSE WE
DESERVE THE TRUTH.
BUT WHAT IS PROBLEMATIC FOR
DEMOCRATS IS WHAT HE IS TALKING
ABOUT, I DON'T THINK WE WILL
FIND ANYTHING NEW.
I DON'T THINK THEY WILL JOSTLE
ROBERT MUELLER'S BRAIN, OH, MY
GOSH MY TOTALLY FORGOT.
THERE WAS JUST ONE THING AND I
MEANT TO CHARGE IT AND HE HAS TO
BE REMOVED FROM OFFICE NOW.
THEN HILLARY SLIDES IN.
>> Juan: HERE IS TO THAT
POINT.
THE REAL QUESTION THAT DEMOCRATS
CAN ASK.
SOMETHING WE ALL WANT TO KNOW
FOR DEMOCRATS.
IS THERE A REASON YOU CHOSE NOT
TO INDICT THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE
OF JUSTICE OF POLICY?
AND IF THAT IS THE CASE, WHY
DIDN'T YOU TALK TO THE
PRESIDENT?
WHY DIDN'T YOU TALK TO JOHN JR.?
WHY DID YOU MAKE THESE
CONCLUSIONS.
>> Jesse: BECAUSE JOHN JR.
DIDN'T SPEAK TO THE MUELLER --
HE SPOKE AND THE PRESIDENT GAVE
WRITTEN ANSWERS.
>> Juan: NOT TO MUELLER.
>> Jesse: YES HE DID.
WHEN YOU ARE OUT IN THE STREETS
COME OUT IN THE BARS WITH YOUR
PEOPLE?
>> Tyrence: WHEN YOU ARE OUT
PICKING?
UNDER CHERRY TREES, ENJOYING
WINE.
>> Jesse: HAS ANYBODY CAME UP
TO YOU AND SAID MUELLER --
>> Tyrence: NO, BECAUSE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE JUST LIKE MYSELF
AND WE HAVE MOVED ON FROM THIS.
HERE IS THE THING.
MUELLER, THAT WAS THE POINT OF
THE WHOLE REPORT.
HE IS NOT GOING TO MAKE NEW LAW
OR PERSONAL OPINIONS.
I THINK PEOPLE WANTED HIM TO
SAY, HEY WHAT WOULD YOU DO IN
THAT SITUATION?
BASED ON THE LAWS IN FRONT OF
ME.
IT IS THE SAME THING.
IF THE RULES ARE DIFFERENT AS
FAR AS A SITTING PRESIDENT CAN
AND CAN'T DO, WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THAT.
BUT HE'S NOT GOING TO CREATE --
THAT'S WHAT THE SUPREME COURT IS
FOR AND THAT'S NOT WHAT MUELLER
WILL DO.
>> IF YOU READ THE MUELLER
REPORT VOLUME 1, VOLUME 2 AT THE
END OF THE DAY NO INVESTIGATION
WAS OBSTRUCTED.
NOT THE FBI COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION, NOT THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION, 500 SEARCH
WARRANTS, NO WITNESSES
INTERFERED AND THEY CAN
INTERVIEW ANYBODY THEY WANTED TO
EVEN PEOPLE IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Jesse: TO THAT POINT THE
BIG ENTREE WAS COLLUSION.
AND THEY DIDN'T FIND IN A
CONSPIRACY TO COLLUDE WITH THE
RUSSIANS TO INTERFERE IN THE
ELECTION.
I THINK THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
HAS MOVED ON.
>> Juan: WAIT A SECOND, THEY
DID FIND MANY INSTANCES MORE
THAN 100 OF CONTEXT.
>> Jesse: NOT ILLEGAL, JUAN
NOT A CRIME.
>> Juan: THEY DID NOT FIND A
CONSPIRACY OR ANY THINK THAT
THIS IS SO 100% LOCKED IN.
>> Jesse:
>> Besse:
>> BUTse:
>> BUT T:
>> BUT THAT IS THE LAW.
>> Jesse: INFLUENCES CAMPAIGN
AND THE RUSSIANS WANTED
DONALD TRUMP TO WIN, THAT IS
ALL.
THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE.
FROM UP THERE FROM THE
CONGRESSMAN, NEVER.
I WOULD SAY IF YOU ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE LOOKING INTO RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE INTO THE ELECTION,
WHY DIDN'T YOU NOT LOOK INTO
HILLARY CLINTON DOSSIER?
>> BUT THAT IS A FAIR QUESTION.
IF YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
CONTACTS FROM RUSSIA, IF THAT IS
THE THRESHOLD, JUAN A LOT OF
RUSSIANS WHO HAD CONTACT WITH
THE PERSON BEING PAID
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS BY THE DNC.
IF IT IS PROBLEMATIC TO HAVE
RUSSIANS GIVING INFORMATION IN
ORDER TO AFFECT THE OUTCOME OF
AN ELECTION, THAT HAS TO BE
PROBLEMATIC AS WELL IF WE ARE
GOING TO BE CONSISTENT AND
APPLY --
>> Juan: CLEARLY, YOU KNOW
WHAT, AN AMERICAN COMPANY AND
YOU CAN HIRE AN AMERICAN COMPANY
TO DO WHATEVER YOU WANT.
>> Jesse: THEY CAN GO TO THE
RUSSIANS AND SAY, HEY --
>> THAT IS DIFFERENT THAN HAVING